muchas personas están reunidas aquí en
kiev en la catedral San Miguel para
despedirse de la escritora ucraniana
Victoria a Medina su muerte es un gran
pérdida para la literatura ucraniana y
también para los ucranianos que conocían
además de su obra de ficción también su
trabajo de documentación sobre los
crímenes de guerra cometidos por Rusia
Victoria se describió a sí misma como
parte del nuevo Renacimiento ejecutado
esta expresión utilizada para describir
los artistas los intelectuales los
escritores los poetas asesinados Durante
los años 20 y 30 del siglo pasado por
los soviéticos ahora vemos una nueva
generación de víctimas esta vez de
misiles rusos y Quiero compartir unas
palabras de Victoria Medina escritas el
año pasado en abril
2022 justamente sobre ataques aéreas
Se dispara una alerta aérea en mi país
es como Si estuvieran aquí de nuevo para
ejecutarnos pero solo mata uno suele ser
alguien al azar hoy no eres tú otro día
se ha ido
Pues esta vez como miles de otros
civiles en el país ha sido Victoria